you
if you're just joining us rudy giuliani
is sweating his face off explaining to
us why trump really won the election
again inspectors
every state
almost every approved this
was thrown away
gone for eternity is this a skit the
only thing left is to have been a dead
person
that could have been not filled out wait
he's saying there was a dead person in
the envelope
rudy's about to have actual drops of
sweat coming off of his brow i mean is
this a normal amount i don't know how
hot it is in the room but this something
seems very wrong here all being the
lawsuit that comes out duty's melting
arizona is a k is a state that we're
looking at very very carefully strongly
looking at it i would say we're probably
i assume she's working if she's working
for them
i'd like to read them all to you but i
don't have the time
you should have had the time and energy
to go look for that
[Music]
that's your job
like it's my job to defend the president
michigan wisconsin is is he bleeding did
you see is he bleeding from his ear
what on earth was that needed
to find out
does that hair dye is to look at the
lawsuits in order to do it it looks like
blood
but in the maturity oh my god it's
everywhere ten
thousand at least
and we're getting he's gotta get off the
stage and there are other aspects of
this fraud on the morning of november
someone's got to get him a napkin they
were going to count the these this new
kind of battle
i've never seen anything like this
what on earth it's getting onto his
shirt now
and it was con any jury would accept as
they heard this evidence
that somebody had this plan this is
insane maybe that was always the plan
it looks like sapped from an oak tree or
a maple tree it looks like someone's
making syrup the city described that to
you oh my god it's all over his face
he's gonna need a towel dealing with
evidence i don't know guys it's sounding
like trump won isn't it based on this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right here
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we are
standing by for the pennsylvania
republican senate primary debate as some
of you know
the democratic debate is happening right
now there's about 15 minutes left in it
i wasn't able to cover it from the
beginning i don't really like covering
things piecemeal so i'm aware that it's
going on i'm supporting this guy john
fetterman now interestingly you guys may
remember when dave rubin
said he was supporting caitlyn jenner
for governor of california and then
caitlyn's campaign didn't return dave's
call and then he abandoned support for
her fetterman's ignoring us
i still support him i think he's the
best candidate and i don't i don't
really like covering stuff piecemeal so
i'm not going to go to it but it is
going on and if people want to tune away
from my stream i won't be offended but
what the hell would you be doing that
would be crazy more importantly we're
still trying to find a reliable stream
for the republican piece which will
start at 8. i'm hoping that this youtube
channel pcn tv which is currently
running the democratic debate will have
the republican one but in case they
don't we're monitoring all these other
websites which supposedly are covering
the stream and many of them may get us
canceled
because lo it's all local news
uh i don't know but anyway the hope is
that at 8 p.m
this channel will switch to a republican
element
and that then we'll be able to do
that now why do we care so much about
the pennsylvania senate race well we
care about it because it quite literally
may decide whether republicans or
democrats control the senate starting in
2023 but sir how could that be
well
let's take a look
um there are some really good maps
on 270 to win
and we start with
this is the incumbent map of those who
are up for re-election
um and then when we look at the 2022
consensus map you see that there's only
a few states here
that are
true toss-ups there's five
so when it's so close
any one of these five could be the
decider
and when you look at the different maps
pennsylvania is on just about every one
of these if you look at sabato's crystal
ball
pennsylvania is a toss-up and it could
be the decider if you look at the cook
political report pennsylvania is a
toss-up and it could be the decider uh
inside elections has it leaning red
although it's really a question mark
and politico
has pennsylvania also as a toss-up so
this in in
it's horrifying to acknowledge this
because it's sort of like trump again or
it's like are we really
does does the country come down to
celebrities
and
dr oz
winning might give the senate to
republicans it's that depressing
it's that depressing and so that's why
we are very closely monitoring
this debate so the democratic debate is
about to wrap up
then there will be a republican debate
hopefully we will have a good stream
uh
of it
and we just we don't always know
and we're doing the the best we can and
if anybody knows of a definitive stream
let me know but we have all these
different streams that we're monitoring
this page says where does it say it
hold on
the debate will live stream here at 8
so i'm hoping that if we refresh this at
eight we'll have something
a lot of these are just duplicates like
this one this one says the same thing
even though it's a different website
it's crazy when the it it's such a mess
uh but in any case
we're monitoring it all extremely
extremely closely now in the meantime i
have some i want to go over some
marjorie taylor green stuff with you
guys before i do that thanks to scifly
fpv
for the twitch prime subscription you
are new member number one also big thank
you to kevin gouldy and andrew kulp
they've just gifted two subscriptions on
my website
and those subscriptions now go
to some really great people
lindsay thurgood and craig asbury
i really appreciate that and of course
you can gift subscriptions at your
leisure
on my website let's go to some marjorie
taylor green stuff marjorie taylor green
unfortunately
committed
heavy
heavy perjury the other day okay
first and foremost oh let i
i'm not really set up for this we're
gonna do this on the fly i'm gonna try
to produce this on the fly let's see
green
let me see if i can get this all done
okay
so
during the
um
testimony here's what marjorie taylor
greene had to say
about anthony aguero ms green did you or
any member of your government or
campaign staff
communicate
with anthony aguero
about the events of january 6th prior to
january 6th i don't recall okay i don't
recall
then she was also oh see i'm not really
set up for this i'm going to do the best
i can okay she also said like he's not
really a great friend of hers okay but
unfortunately this now
now uncovered video
says otherwise
because my friend anthony is my dear
dear friend uh oh
uh oh
wait what did she say
because my friend anthony is my dear
dear friend okay so i'll get the clip in
time for tomorrow
but what she said under oath was that
it's like some kind of distant friend or
something like that
you know i don't really know so that's
one example of the
um of the perjury now of course we're
using the term perjury colloquially it's
very hard to legally prove
that someone
remembered something they claimed not to
but okay here's a text message from
marjorie taylor green to mark meadows in
our private chat with only members
several are saying the only way to save
our republic is for trump to call for
martial law now she's also misspelled
marshall it's m-a-r-t-i-a-l
i'm not even gonna deal with that okay
when she was asked about martial law
here is what she had to say
uh mrs green did you advocate to
president trump to impose martial law as
a way to remain in power i don't recall
he said you're not denying you did it
you just don't remember i don't remember
okay so i mean like again now of course
she might genuinely not remember but
that seems extraordinarily unlikely
here's another one this is another clip
from marjorie taylor green's testimony
the other day
whoops hold on a second this isn't the
one here it is
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it
and um
we were so confused we thought antifa
was breaking in or blm because of those
were the riots that had gone on so she
claimed under oath that she believed
that it was antifa or black lives matter
that was breaking in and rioting however
we now have the text message that she
sent while this was all happening and
she said to mark meadows mark i was just
told there's an active shooter on the
first floor of the capitol please tell
the president to calm people this isn't
the way to solve anything this text
message makes no mention of the fact
that she thought it was antifa or that
she thought it was black lives matter
and black lives matter and antifa don't
like trump so why would you suggest that
trump try to calm those people down
so it's perjury all the way down and i
know guys i know you can't prove that
she was lying when she said she didn't
remember but it seems abundantly clear
abundantly clear that that's the case so
lie after lie after lie obviously
she was lying the entire time
um i want to say thank you to david
morse who just signed up on my website
joinpackman.com welcome welcome welcome
uh even if okay so here's a fair
question
if elon musk buys twitch will i still
accept twitch prime
yes i will okay i don't know why not
right now we call them bezos bucks
whenever someone signs up with twitch
prime we call it taking a few bezos
bucks out of bezos pocket um
sure if elon buys uh twitch then we'll
call them
i guess musk bucks or something like
that i don't know
it seems completely fine
seems completely fine
we are standing by for the republican
debate it will be at the top of the hour
we hope to have a feed of it let's
listen to a little bit of the democratic
debate taking place believe that you you
said you wanted to
let me okay
so what do you propose for uh
what would uh what kind of energy source
would would you use for manufacturing
and keeping manufacturing in
pennsylvania well thank you for asking
asking that question and so for folks at
home if you want an environmental
champion as your next senator clearly
there's only one person on the stage for
you
dude you got to answer the question not
approve new permits for new drilling we
know right now that even across the
country we have 9 000 plus permits right
now that are approved where there is no
drilling and so companies who already
have those permits they could do more
drilling if they want to right now we
have to stop acting and acting as if big
polluters care about their workers and
this is about the workers those big
polluters don't give a damn about work
that wasn't the question i asked howard
you didn't ask how are you going to
bring manufacturing manufacturing no no
it was about what will you do for
manufacturing we need energy to
manufacture you can't do it we don't
currently have
if you get rid of the fracking we get
rid of oil how are we going to
manufacture and keep jobs in
pennsylvania
that's really the question
no
that doesn't look good
congressman that doesn't look like thank
you my question is also for the
lieutenant governor one of my grave
concerns about his candidacy is that uh
i don't believe he can appeal to the
types of swing voters that we need to
win in november these are the types of
people i've been campaigning around for
the last four years they've elected me
in districts that favor republicans and
they if anything play an outsized role
in a midterm election year like this one
they don't like chaos
they don't like instability
and they're very very concerned about
both inflation and the overall size of
the national debt so my question for
john is very simple it's a yes or no
do you still support medicare for all
would you vote for the medicare for all
bill yes or no
thank you connor um i support
universal health care i support health
care as a basic fundamental human right
i support whatever means gets us there
whether that's the affordable care act
whether that's
the public option whether that's
medicare for all i am for allowing
congress and the federal government to
negotiate for lower drug prices i am for
lowering the medicare
eligibility age i am for adding vision
uh dental and hearing as well too i am
for making sure that americans have
greater access to health care yeah but
to his question medicare for all you
support and i answer that i said
whatever whatever mechanism gets us
closer to
health care to health care as a
fundamental human right i'm going to
support if conor if if conor uh wants to
be for the insurance companies that's
his right but i'm for health care and
making sure that it's a fundamental
human right for every american guys the
echo is on the audio it's not on my end
drug prices is at the heart of that
immediately
but
you know he said yes no and i would like
to get a yes no as well i mean when you
say getting closer does that mean
medicare for all
it means whatever is in front of us as
as a congress to get greater
access to health care for america
and my vote is decisive i would
absolutely support it that's how you
know a 20-year politician even though
i'd give you a yes or no i'd like to say
i support it i support medicare for all
i support i should have just asked you
no well i suppose i can cause i can
answer because you know what this
weekend i was in schuylkill county and i
met a woman who didn't have health
insurance
all right all right that's real that's
not a joke
yes i do okay okay this isn't feeling
like anybody's very polished i have to
say question of one of the uh other uh
panel members
hmm
yeah
connor it's for for representative lam
um
how do you feel about
your endorsement joe manchin endorsing
you through this race and would you
vote similarly to to him in the uh
in the senate you know my fear my fear
is is that i think we have one joe
manchin is enough in the senate and you
know his endorsement of you in this race
i found troubling because i absolutely
disagree with his voting record let him
answer your question then
yeah to be honest when john says that
i'm not sure what he's referring to when
i was a member of congress
i held fundraisers with many senators
and other members of congress including
senator manchin again when i was a
member of congress not a senate
candidate uh and the question of how we
vote is actually already answered by our
actual votes we both have voting records
i voted for the john lewis voting rights
act three times and said we should get
rid of the filibuster i voted for the
women's health protection act i voted
for raising the minimum wage to fifteen
dollars an hour and i voted for the
build back better act to my knowledge
he's been against all four of them
joe manchin is conor's mentor and he did
host the fundraiser for for conor and he
just said recently that he would make a
heck of a senator so i mean that's
that's an endorsement and i'm just
saying do you embrace joe manchin's
endorsement of you in 2020 it's you know
you wanted a yes no answer and i'm
asking you yes or no do you embrace joe
manchin's endorsement in the 2022
election
well you have as hard of a time asking
questions as you have answering them
again when i was in
congress he appeared at a fundraiser for
me and expressed his support for me as a
member of congress i accepted it then of
course i did uh my voting record is what
it is i'll work with any democrat to get
things done i have no problem i like
fetterman but lamb's the only one who's
even remotely prepared for this debate
the question is factually incorrect but
if you're asking me if i'll accept the
support of a democratic senator who
supports my campaign absolutely
joe manchin supported he said you make a
heck of a senator and i'm saying do you
embrace his endorsement yes or no see
while they're talking about this people
at home want to know what we're gonna do
actually as their next senator and
here's the good news for folks watching
at home you don't have to vote for
either of them you can actually vote for
malcolm king
but i think
joe manchin i think this is really
important why why bring up joe manchin
joe manchin has been the state senator i
am very worried that no matter who wins
from these four this is this is not a
policy analysis guys
i think dr oz or dave mccormick would
both crush any of these four i i
rhetorically i'm very concerned about if
the if control of the senate comes down
to this race i'm scared i'm not i'm not
going to lie guys i'm scared not go down
we can never become west virginia do we
cannot ever allow any politician to do
what
what joe manchin did to west virginia
all right on this question it's a little
bit different i'm going to ask for
you to raise your hands
in a way kind of a yes no question but
for democracy related uh questions
and i believe this goes to
representative kenyatta i'll take it
sign me up
they're not just all right
oh no they're all going to get it oh
that's right okay
sorry the moderator's
a pretty scuffed debate guys four
questions about democracy and just get
you to raise your hand
raise your hand if you support the
positions or issues i mentioned and then
we'll discuss afterwards raise your hand
if you support
abolishing the electoral college
and this is as a group right that's
right but maybe i'm alone okay that's
fine
okay okay
uh and we will go back
eliminating the senate filibuster
all four okay
expanding the number of justices on the
u.s supreme court
okay
making the district of columbia and
puerto rico u.s states
okay
all right so let's go back to
where there was some some disagreement
abolishing the electoral college
representative kenyatta why do you want
to abolish the electoral college well
for folks at home who care about
abolishing electoral college yet again
you only have one option on this stage
the electoral college serves no purpose
other than to continue
to muddy up this idea that there should
be one person in one vote i will tell
you on this stage if any one of us gets
one more vote than the other person that
person will be the democratic nominee
and yet with the electoral college we've
seen we've seen multiple elections now
where the person who got the most votes
did not become president
that is a problem and i think it erodes
people's faith i agree here i'll get the
other three candidates to answer this as
well uh lieutenant governor fetterman
why don't you want to abolish that i
don't and because we're democrats um
we can't be in a position where we are
contradicting ourselves if
if we go after the republicans
understandably that they're frustrated
by an outcome and they go to to
legitimize it or to go change the
structure of it as they attempted to do
with our own supreme court here in
pennsylvania and change the underlying
rules there um i i believe that we as as
a party need to remain logically
consistent on these things
we need to make sure that we're not
changing the structure of our government
at a fundamental no no no if we all
agree on the changes in advance that's a
different i don't i don't like this
answer from fetterman abolishing the
electoral college you know
president obama a guy named barack
hussein obama the man of mixed race won
twice
he won the electoral
one as well you win elections you'll
lose elections we cannot act like uh the
last president and just get upset say
well we're gonna change does anybody
know how obama's race is relevant to the
electoral college joe biden won the
electoral college and he won the popular
vote what's more important is that our
candidates speak clearly and now clear
message congressman lamb i actually
think if we were starting our society
over again from scratch it would make a
lot of sense not to have an electoral
college but we have one and to get rid
of it you would have to amend the
constitution anybody who doesn't know
how difficult that is just look it up
it's not happening that's actually not
true you've got the national popular
vote interstate compact can i respond to
this because i think
to suggest that abolishing the electoral
college which is a relic of the past
which has not served us is the same as
trump trying to overturn the last
election
we don't try to change anything or well
it's in the constitution therefore it's
hard so this guy coming from behind
quickly that does not make a lot of
sense the constitution has mechanisms by
which it could be changed because our
founders understood it was a living
breathing document i'm running for us
there's a lot of stuff trying to change
well done by malcolm kenyatta he was
completely off the wall to just not
answer the earlier question but he's 100
right here her hands again i think it
was just was about okay
okay so it's just the two of you yes
just okay congress uh woman yeah i'll
start with you
did i say congress that's okay you can
call me that's fine people changing town
would love it uh well i would tell you
the reason is what you know everyone
will argue well we're democrats we don't
change what has happened is that this
particular supreme court has decided it
wants to overturn everything from the
new deal their desire is that the way
our way of life they want to overturn
they have been planning this for a long
time with the federalist society this uh
with in particular sam alito
they have been planning steadily to go
ahead and erode the entire new deal
philosophies and and policies social
security medicare time representative
can you not even answer first of all
this is not a new idea i wish i could
take credit for it but i can't we've
expanded the number of justices on the
bench multiple times throughout the
history of our country i think that it
was mitch mcconnell not democrats who
packed the court when mitch mcconnell
did not allow president obama to
actually appoint somebody when it was
his turn to ram through amy coney
barrett um in opposition of the same
rule that he made up to deny president
obama's seat on the bench the supreme
court has its lowest public trust than
it's ever had we have to fix that all
right lieutenant governor federer some
good answers here i have to say
it's the same underlying logic you know
just in the pennsylvania state supreme
court the republicans were outraged they
were unhappy with the judgments of the
supreme court duly elected supreme court
here in pennsylvania and now they wanted
to change our constitution to change how
i'm unsure about packing the court but i
thought his answer was fine in a
republican supreme court here in
pennsylvania the democratic party does
not rig the rules just simply because we
do not like the outcome i wish we had a
six to three uh democratic majority in
the supreme court but but the fact is
that we don't and i don't believe
fundamentally altering the structure of
the supreme court is the answer
congressman
yeah i mean i just think this whole
question is a trap one of the things i'm
trying to convey here is i've spent four
years knocking on the doors of answering
questions of at town halls the exact
type of people that are going to
determine whether we are successful or
fail this year never had a single one of
them in tens of thousands of
conversations asking me to add a justice
to the supreme court people are looking
for a little bit of stability and
practicality in our priorities they want
to know where do we really stand at the
end of the day
most people's lives won't be
destabilized by adding some justices
that i don't agree with and now is a
wasted moment i want to go back to our
right yeah can we both be here we i have
the same thing i have to agree you know
if if roe v wade
is overturned if they start attacking
uh what we see going on with voting
rights uh the environment recently the
clean water act if they start going
after medicare if they start really
going after social security there's a
lot of things that disagree
aren't you doing that they're saying
that you there's decisions
to my esteemed colleagues here no one
here is fdr and he tried to do and he
wanted to do it too and you know he was
a great democrat who did great things
for this country yes you're right no one
is asking it but why what did the fdr do
he said if you will not allow us to help
the american people oh fetterman seems
bored american people can john this will
have to be the last word on this one no
thank you
i think that there's a couple of things
that are being said here that are
fundamentally false
we're not going to win this election by
only going to doors in western
pennsylvania that the congressman keeps
referencing the doors that we need to
also be focused on maybe even more
focused on are the doors of that are in
philadelphia and southeastern
pennsylvania the base of our party and
we keep acting as if the folks who show
up for democrats every election are
somehow not as worth fighting for as
some other folks we're going to win this
election by turning out folks in
philadelphia and southeastern
pennsylvania all right i want to go back
to our questioners now evie dejesus
offend live has the next question and
this is for representative kenyatta
representative kenyatta we're going to
go back to energy for a minute president
biden recently walked back a campaign
pledge to end new drilling on permits on
public lands do you agree and how do you
see pennsylvania's role in the natural
gas economy
well i'm going to have to agree with
president with candidate biden and
disagree with with with what he did
there what i do support is releasing
more petroleum out of the strategic
petroleum reserve what i do support is
actually making sure that we don't give
one
cent more in tax breaks to big polluters
and actually put our investments into
clean technologies of the future and
what i have said repeatedly is that a
part of the increase that people are
feeling at the pump the sheets down the
street 409 before before i came here a
part of that we have to acknowledge is
that big oil and gas ceos are making
more money than they've ever made and
are not passing on those savings to the
consumers and there are a number of
different bills that people are talking
about right now in washington to make
sure that they cannot
do the type of greedy
practices that have allowed companies
like shell and bp to make more money
than they've ever made
while still
let's see if we uh have the start to the
uh republican debate it looks like it's
not there let's see if we refresh here
um the stream will be here
uh
at 8 pm
not seeing it there
let's try this one
um
looks like it might be coming up here in
a moment
let's check this web like all these
different websites supposedly are
carrying it but
live now republican debate oh hold on
let's see
let's see if we can get this all squared
away
live now we'll be right back
huh i think i can probably pick this up
if we need to first statewide debate
dave mccormick okay
kathy
headquarters in harrisburg pennsylvania
this is the pennsylvania republican
primary u.s senate debate
we'll get it good evening welcome and
thanks so much for joining us tonight
i'm dennis owens with abc 27 news in
harrisburg and i'm lisa silvester with
wpxi channel 11 news in pittsburgh we
are broadcasting and streaming live
across every county in the commonwealth
the four republican candidates standing
on the stage tonight have a good power
eligibility criteria each hoping to
become the next senator from
pennsylvania so here are the rules for
tonight's debate each candidate will get
60 seconds to answer a question the
candidate will get 30 seconds to answer
if there's a follow-up or rebuttal and
if a clarification is needed they will
have 15 seconds we just went up on
candidates throughout the night of those
times the sound of a bell will ring when
their time is up
our bell is working as you can hear you
are watching tonight's debate from one
of our next star media stations across
the state and our partner station in
pittsburgh
wpxi tv
all right we want to get right to what
people want to know so how did each of
you end up running for a u.s senate seat
in pennsylvania according to our next
star emerson college of the hill poll
more than 70 percent of republican
voters said the amount of time a
candidate has lived in pennsylvania is
important we begin with mr mccormick
you've been campaigning on your
pennsylvania roots but you have not
actually lived in pennsylvania for the
last 15 years so explain
why it seems that you return to the
commonwealth just in time to run for the
u.s senate mr mccormick you have 60
seconds listen i'm a seventh generation
pennsylvanian uh i grew up uh in
bloomsburg pennsylvania smells like
trump family farm and i spent the first
18 years of my life
hunting and fishing and playing sports
and then i went to west point and so i
left for my first tour of duty to west
point the army spent five years in the
army where i was a combat veteran in the
82nd airborne division then i came back
to pennsylvania and i spent 10 years
building a great company in pittsburgh
that created 600 jobs and throughout
that time throughout my entire life
we've had the family farm for 45 years
and i've been the owner of that family
farm for the last 10 years so my
pennsylvania roots are deep i'm very
connected to my friends where i grew up
and i'm very connected to the people of
pennsylvania and it'd be a powerful
privilege to be able to represent them
in the senate all right thank you mr
mccormick turning to you mr oz uh except
for your time attending medical school
and graduate school you have not
actually lived in the commonwealth in
pennsylvania so how do you respond to
concerns that you do not know what is
best for pennsylvanians you have 60
seconds sir well pennsylvanians that i
speak to are quite clear they care much
more about what i stand for than where
i'm from but i didn't grow up less than
10 miles from kenneth square where my
father learned a lot about mushrooms he
was an immigrant recruited to this
country as a doctor and he would always
tell me don't be a mushroom when you
grow up and to make sure i did not sit
in the dark all day long i get fed
manure and then get canned at the end of
it all i went to medical school penn
business school warden and then the
biggest the most important decision of
my life i met and married my wife lisa
we actually live in the house we were
married in
all right thank you mr osmond where is
the house in pennsylvania since you were
quite young and we know that
pennsylvania voters value their deep
roots here but you're not polling higher
what do you feel you have to do in order
to improve your poll numbers you have 60
seconds actually in the last poll in the
trevocker poll i am essentially at a
three-way statistical tie for first
place
direct result of the people here in
pennsylvania because they want one of
their own you know i don't make many
promises on the campaign trail but i can
promise the people of pennsylvania that
when these carpet baggers lose you will
never see them again and if they should
win you will never see them again and i
think we've gone through two of the
worst years of our lives right
during the pandemic and and and on and i
believe people are very concerned about
making sure that our voices are
represented by someone who doesn't just
parachute into our state because it's an
opportune time for them to do so and
then once they if they should win then
they leave and we have no voice this
seat is too important to just throw away
our voice like that all right thank you
very much miss barnett uh turning to you
mr bardos in that trafalgar poll that uh
miss barnett referenced you are running
in the back of the pack of the dead last
on the stage tonight you recently
expressed some frustration that you've
been campaigning for years while some of
your other your political opponents only
recently got into the race mr bartos how
do you explain why you are trailing in
the polls what are you doing here sir
well i'm a lifelong pennsylvanian
proudly raised in berks county uh
married a pennsylvania girl grew up in
allentown we've raised our two girls in
the state and i think there's a key
difference the reason 40 of the
republican electorate right now remains
undecided is because they're trying to
figure out who do they trust who do they
trust to actually do what they say
they're going to do and you're going to
hear this a lot tonight there's a lot of
words words words from a lot of the
candidates i'm the only candidate
running who has a proven track record of
actually getting things done for the
people of pennsylvania when the
democrats shut us down when tom wolf and
john fetterman shut us down the last two
years i rolled up my sleeves i gathered
a great group of leaders we raised three
and a half million dollars and helped
over a thousand women and men across all
67 counties keep the lights on in their
small businesses saving thousands of
jobs sir could you have possibly chosen
a more vile suit color for them because
i always have i always will because i
always have
that's the key differentiator in this
race
a lot of words from the other candidates
i'm a doer i'm a fighter
i'm going to win this race because
pennsylvania's now they trust me to go
down there and fight for them there you
go all right thank you mr bartos miss
sands you grew up in cumberland county
in fact not very far away from where
you're standing right now but you spent
most of your time outside of the
commonwealth so same question why does
it appear that you perhaps are not
connecting with pennsylvania voters 60
seconds to respond well i am connecting
with pennsylvania voters i am an eighth
generation pennsylvanian so i've my
family's been in pennsylvania longer
than anyone else in this race and as a
matter of fact my first real job was at
hershey park
and i live close to my elderly parents
and my sister and brother there's only
one person on this stage that has spent
more time in pennsylvania than me and
that's jeff
because i've spent about half my life
here i've worked as a third generation
doctor of chiropractic with my father
oh [ __ ] went to denmark and uh served as
the u.s ambassador throw him the house
denmark greenland and the faroe islands
so i voted and paid taxes in
pennsylvania even when i was serving
abroad on behalf of all pennsylvanians
and all americans as well working to
counter rush she's a chiropractor dr oz
is an md but has she ever suggested
people drink silver because i actually
increased our trade with my great team
over 43 percent while i was there so
there's no one else in this race who's
more pennsylvanian than i am all right
thank you miss sands dennis well we've
all seen them therefore we can't ignore
them we need to
hear about the attack ads that have been
flooding tvs phones and mailboxes across
pennsylvania an unprecedented amount of
money tens of millions of dollars so far
has been spent much of it on negative
advertising directly wait the
chiropractor was caught using the n-word
is that what people are saying is that
is that true you've heard sir but you've
been called a hollywood liberal and a
rhino republican in name only what do
you say to the critics who are saying
that you have 30 seconds these are ads
primarily run by one of my opponents mr
mccormick and they're designed to try to
fool the electorate uh mr mccormick
approached president trump with these
types of information that was unable to
pull the will over his eyes president
trump saw right through him he therefore
did not endorse mr mccormick he endorsed
me and out of that and another slew of
these ads has arisen once again trying
to tell pennsylvanians something that
president trump does not believe is true
and i can say categorically is not true
okay mr mccormack can attack ad claims
that you made billions of dollars for
china and millions for yourself as a
hedge fund manager in 30 seconds what is
your response to that question
listen um i've been a successful
businessman i've run two businesses
i served in our military for 10 years
fighting against the communists i
negotiate the highest levels against the
chinese and other countries
the communist national security council
and i've done business around the world
in 20 countries including two percent of
our business in china and it's just
disingenuous for member to say that when
mehmet has so many dollars coming in his
pocket from china which we can talk
about that it's sort of mind-boggling
and we can talk more about the negative
ads because the negative as in my case
this is going to be a hell of an
election season i'm realizing really
quickly you've also been accused of
flip-flopping on key conservative issues
like abortions that's true
that's true you said you support
overturning roe versus wade should there
be exceptions for rape incest or the
life of the mother 30 seconds president
trump endorsed me quite clearly in the
first point he made about why i'm a
conservative america first
republican he said that i am pro-life
and i am pro-life i've been very clear
on my position throughout this race what
about the exception to my knowledge
evidence that i'm not pro-life in fact
in crowded groups i've been always out
there saying that i'm pro-life even if
everyone else in the group is pro-choice
and i voted to proudly proclaim as a
heart surgeon who's taking care of
little babies four or five days old i
met one recently actually that you know
has now grown up to become a teenager
but saving those children's he recently
met a baby and it's already a teenager
there be an exception
there should be an exception for the
life of the mother we don't want mothers
dying as they try to give birth to a
child mr mccormick's
also with you if roe versus wade is
overturned should there be exceptions
for rape and sister the life of the
mother and we will hear from everybody
on this you have 30 seconds sir well i
want to say
mehmet has flip-flopped on every major
issue and you can go to his own comments
may 21 2019 an interview at the
breakfast club he essentially said that
he was worried about the pro-life
movement
that was creating fights he was worried
about states putting in place pro-life
legislation and he called into question
when life begins uh at conception so
it's it's just not true it's in his own
words which are all these things are in
his own way it's completely true that
memit has flip-flopped on the issue of
abortion i believe in the very rare
instances there should be exceptions for
life of the mother okay i want to move
to ms barnett you have 30 seconds you
have spoken passionately about the issue
of abortion while on the campaign trail
you're very much pro-life should there
be any exceptions in your view you have
30 seconds yeah well actually i actually
should get a minute because you've asked
them two questions and you're just now
getting to me please but a high name id
which is one of which is really one of
the only reasons why mamid oz received
that endorsement works both ways his
name id is so high that people know he's
not a conservative hence the reason why
i'm the only one in that last poll who
shot up and got the benefit out of the
out of that particular endorsement she
was popping up does not belong to
president trump maga although he coined
the word mega is actually it belongs to
the people our values never
never shifted to president trump's
values it was president trump who
shifted and aligned with our values shot
out of a candidate martos you two are
pro-life should there be exceptions or
do you support an entire ban of abortion
30 seconds well wait before we get to
that i your vote your viewers at home
should play a drinking game every time
these kids talk about themselves oh my
god this election has to be about the
voters it has to be about you the voters
not about us they've made this about
themselves they've spent 60 million
dollars fighting with each other
and people pat themselves on the back
and bang their chest about how wonderful
they are this election is about fighting
for the people of pennsylvania making
pennsylvania what she can be we can't
have this we have to beat the democrats
in november well that's why where have
these guys been for the last seven ten
years what about your answer dude
conservative principal let me just ask
you though quickly should there be
exceptions when it comes to abortion yes
i believe in exceptions okay let's turn
to miss sans you're also proudly
pro-life
should there be exceptions or should
abortion be banned across the board you
have 30 seconds
i am pro-life at the beginning of life
and at the end of life but i do want to
comment on two of my opponents answer
the question oz says he's pro-life but
as a matter of fact
he's not just not pro-life and we've
just tweeted out his own words that he
is not pro-life but also he's turkey
first he served in the turkish military
not the u.s military uh-oh he chose to
do that he chose to put turkey first and
he has said that the baby's heartbeat is
not a heartbeat it's an electrical
impulse we know that's what a heartbeat
is whoa mccormick he is china first he
made his fortune in china and he is
china first sans thank you very much i
do want to give mr oz a moment uh 15
seconds to respond president trump was
very clear i'm america first i was
obliged to serve for two months in the
infirmary in the turkish military which
i did in order to build visit my parents
as i went through my life i can love my
mother and i can love my country as well
thank you lisa all right moving on we
want to talk about the economy in
american jobs this is a complete and
total mess guys this country is in real
rough shape the supply chain that have
contributed to inflation and product
shortages outsourcing some companies
have said that this is profitable but we
have seen firsthand how this could be
risky in a crisis miss barnett how would
you bring back high paying american jobs
and address the supply chain shortages
please be specific specifically yeah yes
uh much of what we are experiencing if
not almost all of it is as a direct
result of the failed policy though the
democrat party but here's the rub
democrats can change absolutely
everything tomorrow if they wanted to
they would just have to admit that every
single thing they've ever done is said
has been a complete and utter failure
utter failure and what are the odds of
them doing that so when you're looking
at what they've done is not covet that
stopped the supply chain the reason why
the supply chain is the way it is right
now we have twenty percent of the nine
thousand shipping containers sitting
outside of ports and instead of pete
buda jack doing what was necessary
to get the goods and services off those
ships and onto the shelves and grocery
stores he went and took
this seems like a skit yeah buddha jack
would wipe the floor with all four five
of these energy resources into uh being
able to drill and get it out to not just
americans but also to the rest of the
world
democrats have decided to create to
weaponize climate change and to create a
war against energy so that's a real word
salad guys i don't even that's worse
than palin mr bartos how would you bring
jobs back to america how would you also
address the supply chain shortages
please be specific 60 seconds i'm
running to save main street pennsylvania
that's the whole campaign it's been
focused on all 67 counties main streets
the number one way to do it is to
unleash pennsylvania's energy industry
we are sitting on two saudi arabia's
worth of natural gas we can power the
nation and we can power our allies
around the world with pennsylvania
resources and natural gas is a much
cleaner alternative to the coal plants
that are being fired up all around the
world these greenies in europe and
around the country they're they're
making coal happen pennsylvania is not
only the key to keeping vladimir putin
in check and holding him in check and
stopping his war of aggression but is
the key to bringing good paying working
family jobs back here honestly like the
none of these candidates are even
speaking substantively about anything
here to run
they don't know main street pennsylvania
they haven't cared to spend time there
until they decided to run for office you
can't save main street pennsylvania if
you cannot find main street pennsylvania
this is a brutal assault on the english
language your families and what's best
for this place i've lived in my whole
life and live with every fiber am i
being as a united states senator i'll be
in washington fighting for pipelines
getting our gas to market all right
thank you mr bartow it's turning to you
mr sands in 60 seconds how would you
bring back high paying american jobs and
how would you address the supply chain
shortages 60 seconds
thank you
it is so important that we bring back
those jobs we saw under the trump
economy that we had record levels of
employment for women minorities the
least educated and he was beginning to
bring back those manufacturing jobs
lowering regulations and making us
competitive with the rest of the world
with our tax structure we have to hold
the line and support the low regulations
i will work to do that in washington
we're going to onshore those jobs the
supply chain in much of the cases right
now is is uh
in trouble because china is locking down
their cities like shanghai and we have
to make things here so i say we bring
those jobs back so basically you've got
this is stepford wife lady
who has no idea what's going on the
woman next to her is so hyped up she
can't even
she every sentence has 20 ideas
then you've got kind of like the
facelift guy in the middle who just is
very creepy then it's mehmet oz who just
says trump every answer and then you've
got possibly the lowest energy person
i've ever seen on the left
mr mccormick turning to you how would
you deal with the supply chain issues
and how would you bring back american
jobs listen first just back to the last
question i might be out pennsylvanian or
out america first by anybody on this
stage i've spent more of my life in
pennsylvania than you and you and mehmet
for sure
not you i've gone uh to the military to
fight for america america first no one
else can say that and then i've created
600 jobs here in pennsylvania in my
company none of you can say that so i
put my track record with pennsylvania
america up against anyone here
jeff's right it's the energy sector is
key to unlocking our economy it's key to
creating jobs here in pennsylvania and
this is what we should be talking about
as candidates on this stage we have to
unlock energy and this is where members
got a real problem
if i were in this and i was trying to
distinguish myself like let's say i
moved to pennsylvania or as they say
pennsylvania and i knew that i was going
to be attacked for how long i was going
to be there i would simply i would try
refusing to engage and i would go listen
i live here now
i understand the problems and i'm not
going to waste any more of the
audience's time
doing a penis-sized contest as to who's
lived here let's talk about solutions
let's talk about them now supply chain
issues
dishonest dave is at it again he went
groveling to president trump with again
these types of allegations president
trump saw right through him did not
endorse him and then he endorsed me
because as he said in his announcement
which he wrote himself i know exactly
how to manage our energy issues and deal
with many of the other factors that we
as a nation have to be strong and bold
on let me speak to the specific answer
as a professor a scientist and someone
who understands a little bit about the
actual energy infrastructure there is no
way the green new deal is going to
provide us what the democrats promised
it's a lie it's a false narrative like
so much of what they said about covet
and so if you look at the architects of
the green new deal you'll realize that
that's why they're shutting down our
ability to harvest natural gas from
under our feet here in pennsylvania
natural gas that could power the entire
country for 200 years they will provide
well-paying jobs here in pennsylvania
and i'll give you a stat if we take our
natural gas and ship it overseas to
replace what they're currently using it
will be the equivalent of electrifying
every vehicle in america plus a solar
panel on every one of your roofs plus
doubling wind energy all together every
year for 30 years all right that's
progress all right thank you mr oz
turning to you uh mr mccormick this is
this is a real cringe stream i i
apologize to you guys keeps talking
about president trump's endorsement is
because he can't run on his own
positions and his own records that's
true and what's true is that he has
flip-flopped on every major issue we're
talking about in this campaign he's
never in his entire media career
advanced a conservative agenda they're
all liberal points liberal agenda that
he put forward and now he's
flip-flopping and the problem doctor is
there's no miracle cure for
flip-flopping and and pennsylvanians are
seeing right ah miracle cure that's what
your let's collect why you're not taking
that
this is for everyone so we can get
everyone weighing in here ms barnett
we're going to turn back miracle cure
that's beautiful president biden for
inflation what is one economic decision
the biden administration has made that
you would vote to reverse miss barnett
do you have 30 seconds to respond yes
thank you so much listen you know for
the overwhelming majority of americans
we've been out here doing what doing the
right things we've been working we've
been paying our bills we've been sending
our kids off to school we've been trying
to put something to the side and right
now and that has generally been the
vehicle towards achieving the american
dream but right now the american people
for those who are
90 those americans who are ninety
percent below uh
the the top ten percent of american
versus the bottom ninety percent of
americans they have been suffering
through not even the beginning of an
answer we weren't even leading to an
answer here
thank you the question was what biden
policy would you reverse if i was them i
would come prepared and i would go
listen the absolute worst thing joe
biden has done
is he
i don't even know i mean what what has
he done economically that's so bad quite
frankly he just hasn't done that much it
was a disaster
everywhere we go and i'd say all of us
because we're all traveling around the
state
everywhere we go from susquehanna county
to washington county from erie to
delaware county
we can't find employees
worker employee employers cannot find
employees so many people are working
there's no free employees that sounds
that sounds like a good problem to have
sir
our economy will not get back on track
until people start working and the wide
administration paid people to stay home
all right thank you mr barton
turning to you miss sans you have 30
seconds one economic decision president
biden made that you would change
disoriented right well it's the out of
control spending i'll stop it the day i
arrive in washington because we're going
to bring more america first senators
than just myself and we will stop the
out of control spending and it's going
to bring down the inflation guys agree
the the deficit is down under biden not
the debt the deficit is down from trump
to biden i will bring down the price at
the pump for them i will bring down that
inflation and give them some relief
carla sands is going to bring down the
price the president can't bring down the
price of gas and she's gonna do it
question what is an economic decision
that you would reverse you have 30
seconds there's three things we could do
to to win back the war on inflation the
first thing we need to do is unlock our
energy sector that was a terrible
decision that's driving the price of
fuel that's driving inflation the second
thing we need to do is put pro-growth
economic policies in place like what
ultimately grow our our economy and
deregulate and the third policy is cut
back dramatically on this spending
republicans democrats alike over the
decades have not been prudent on
spending but what's happened over the
last 18 months biden cut the spending
from trump
in american history we've got to pull
back on the spending those are the
drivers of inflation as a job creator i
know what to do all right thank you mr
mccormick mr oz what is an economic
decision the biden administration has
made that you would like to see changed
30 seconds drinkable nation is building
back better is the republican party and
it's pretty clear to all of us right
here they were getting a tremendous
boost from uh the inadequacies of his
leadership the number one thing i would
do is reverse an executive order passed
january 27th right after he was
inaugurated in 2021 which stopped
drilling on federal lands well at least
he's listing a policy these countries
under those federal lands those lands
are ours at least he answered the
question all of us together there should
be lands that we can drill on it'll
provide us energy independence actually
energy dominance make it easier for us
to help our allies overseas all right
thank you dennis well the phrase america
first has become a rallying cry for the
republican party all of you to some
degree many tonight have embraced it and
on the campaign trail mr bartos we're
going to begin with you do you consider
yourself an america firster and in 60
seconds can you tell us exactly what
that means what a trash president trump
won pennsylvania in 2016 because for the
first time in generations millions of
our fellow pennsylvanians felt listened
to they had felt ignored for generations
and someone was finally listening to
them might as well say which one of you
likes america jobs it means all of the
main streets that i've had the privilege
to travel around the last five years in
all 67 counties meeting working families
meeting farmers meeting the people out
there fighting in our health care
systems to make sure we stay well
fighting to make sure our energy gets to
market
they had someone in the white house
fighting for them and so president
trump's policies remember just three
short years ago we had the best economy
in our lifetimes all of our lifetimes
i'm looking around the room here we're
all young enough to say our lifetimes
unemployment at the absolute low for
every group that's measured people were
working the economy was growing in for
the people unemployment's at an absolute
low right now do these guys have no idea
what's going on america first means
policies that put working families on a
path to growing and climbing that ladder
parents being empowered uh to make the
decisions right for themselves and their
children and safe and secure communities
thank you we're going to turn to miss
sand same question define what america
first means to you and how it would
guide your work as a senator you have 60
seconds thank you so much so everyone
here on this debate stage is talking
about being america first they're all
saying it i actually did it i'm the only
person in this race that was appointed
by president trump to be his ambassador
to denmark greenland and the pharaoh
islands that actually worked in the
administration putting america first
policies forward every single day
also
kathy you should see the way there's
american flags all over the pharaoh
islands now thanks to this woman 20
points in a red wave year and she says
america first but she can't actually
close the deal she lost by 20 points and
it was not it was not stolen by 20
points we need someone who can win this
election it was stolen by 10 so she
still lost by 10. we'll always vote
conservative and america first in
washington you can count on me
they did not steal that election by 20
points she lost her last election to a
weak weak democrat john fetterman is not
a weak democrat he's strong i will beat
john fetterman in the fall thank you uh
i am going to give you 30 seconds to
respond thank you so much for that
because are you saying that there was
absolutely that that that the 2020
election was above par that there was no
fraud that there was no uh issues with
that
are you telling me that it was perfect
and and if and because apparently that's
what she's saying so for all of us in
the republican party now we have a
candidate on stage carlos sand who is
saying that there was absolutely nothing
to see in that 2020 election but beyond
that uh you know you say that you are
america first and you did so much for
president trump and yet he's a gong show
what a joke
hands i'm gonna give you 15 seconds
quickly to respond to that
president trump doesn't always get the
best advice it's unfortunate but true
i'm the only one
i am the only conservative voice no
you're not that every pennsylvania voter
can count on to always put america and
pennsylvania first i actually did it
everyone else talked about thank you
both very much speaking of america first
let's go back to you mr mccormick the
original question in 60 seconds how do
you define america first i thought the
dem debate was bad this is even worse he
put his finger on the fact that there
were many millions of americans and many
millions of pennsylvanians that were
left behind and that the policies and
the leadership didn't take care of him
and i was reminded of this this
crystallized for me
about a month into the campaign and
carbon at least the lighting is better
yeah
and a woman came up to me and she uh
she told me that she wanted to tell me
about her son michael
and michael uh had volunteered for
the military after 9 11 had gone to
afghanistan had been in a terrible
combat situation and came home and was
really struggling and then sadly killed
himself
and she she said when you get to
washington i want you to
watch out for michael watch out for the
michaels of the world she handed me this
gold star
and that's what this is about that's
what america first is about it's about
taking care of the michaels are these
candidates particularly terrible or is
or am i just more cynical because these
these four or five seem particularly bad
they haven't been represented they
haven't been led and that's what america
first is to me thank you turning mr oz
uh former president trump endorsed you
he coined that phrase america first in
60 seconds no he didn't find it exactly
one word
respect
america first goes back to anti-semitic
world war ii stuff trump didn't invent
it
for their turn and they kept getting
pushed out of the way by the federal
government pretending to help and the
reality is when you respect people they
gravitate towards you that's why
president trump has done so well and by
respecting people specifically that
manifest by educating their kids and
that includes by the way protecting them
from indoctrination when they're you
know five six seven years of age but it
also means putting them through high
school so they learn a trade they're
able to go out and actually make a
living and they're in a position where
they can go out and become what
conservatives need to do which is to
populate the country with people who
think about conservative values as they
make their life long decisions
conservatism lives because we respect
each other we have to respect the
working class population they have been
pushed to the side and we can do better
okay miss barnett we're going to turn to
you in 60 seconds what does america
first mean to you
you know um a few moments ago um mammoth
said that that uh magga means respect no
magga means freedom and if you're a
conservative republican you know that
yes president trump coined the word
magga but the word itself make america
great again belongs to the people what
does it mean it means it means the
freedom to live my life the way i choose
to live my life and not to have my
anyone's foot placed on my throat
telling me what i can and cannot do
forcing me to take a jab when i may or
may not want to take a jab forcing me to
do thing or
to teach my children certain curriculum
that i don't want to do that is what the
word means although it was coined by
president trump it certainly belongs to
the people of this great nation and we
need to be very mindful of that and why
do they think trump made that up it's
that's so dumb very clear it doesn't
take much for someone to learn our
talking points as conservative
republicans and then come back on stage
and parrot them to us look at how people
have lived their lives prior to the
opportunity to actually run for this
seat thank you very much we do have a
follow-up for everyone beginning with mr
bartos former president donald trump
continues to talk about the 2020
election is it time for the republican
party to move forward fair question 30
seconds good question fortunately joe
biden's the president and as a result of
his lack of leadership we have chaos in
russia the illegal war of aggression
against ukraine we have chaos in the
middle east we have an ascendant in iran
we have an ascendant china we have an
economy in disarray we have runaway
inflation and this is on the heels of
every democrat running every democrat
running this year is gonna have to
answer for lockdown shutdowns lives
ripped apart
so
the 2020 election was a was a catalyst
for what we're seeing now which is
americans are going to stand up with one
loud voice and pennsylvania certainly
will in november and we are going to
have historic wins in november thank you
miss sands turning to you you have 30
seconds is it time for the gop to move
on and pass the 2020 election well i'll
just refer you and your viewers first of
all dinesh d'souza's new movie just came
out oh no
and it's about this deal of 2020. also
senator rand paul said
the election of 2020 was stolen by the
zuck bucks mark zuckerberg and his
family and his friends
changing the outcome of the election by
private money controlling our election
we have to ban it i'll ban it in
washington on day one i'll work to do
that for all of you but also mehmet oz
says that he's always been uh a
conservative i will just share with you
i just tweeted out my team as we walked
in his statement he's tweeting guys we
need to move on mr mccormick moving to
you should the gop should the gop move
on from the 2020 election you have 30
seconds when you take the oath to
protect this country the thing you're
protecting is our right to vote and we
have a tragedy here that most republican
voters in pennsylvania don't believe in
the integrity of the election it's
terrible there's all sorts of reasons
to worry about it with the extension of
the mail-in ballot and the the lack of
security of the of the ballot boxes the
lack of oversight of precincts and then
you believe hillary using auto
responders on her email during vacations
should be investigated was suppressed so
we've got to fix this we've got to fix
this at the state level we've got to fix
this now we've got to have a governor
that signs the right legislation and the
most important thing
voter id we got to have voter id thank
you we're gonna move to mr oz have you
discussed the 2020 election with former
president trump and do you think it's
time for the party to move on you have
30 seconds sir i have discussed with
president trump but we cannot move on
right so all the candidates up here have
outlined under the cover of covet there
were draconian changes made to our
voting laws by democratic leadership and
they have
appropriate reviews of some of those
decisions we have to be serious about
what happened in 2020 and we won't be
able to address that until we can really
look under the hood okay miss barnett
we're going to turn to you 30 seconds is
it time for the gop to move past that
22. never move on absolutely not there's
nothing more important than making sure
that my one vote matters and we see that
elections have consequences and i
thought it was very interesting that uh
carlos sanz is going to delineate how
the election was not above par and yet
try to throw me under the bus for what i
had no control over we ran an amazing
race in 2020 um but yes elections have
consequences and we must understand what
happened and we must hold people
accountable not just understand but we
need to hold people accountable for what
they did thank you i'd like to respond
right what did they do
yes who did it so as i stated before
kathy played of the same card two years
ago
and she lost by 20 points with that and
she has to take a heart attack
because she did not
they did not stop
miss barnett i'm going to ask what card
was
speaking 15 seconds you go for your
rebuttal we are going then going to be
moving on to another topic we have to
try to get an issue but she called my
name and she made a salacious commentary
so i will be asking you you will get a
chance to respond 15 seconds yes as i
said before
the election of 2020 was not stolen by
20 points ms barnett lost to a weak weak
democrat john fetterman is a strong
democrat i will beat john fetterman in
the fall i have the foreign policy
experience the defense policy experience
thank you
what a waste of an appointment
now i want to just take a moment i want
to take a moment though to remind you of
the rules if you are talking over each
other
no one at home can hear you we are doing
this for the voters just remember that
we are doing this for the voters if you
are speaking over each other no one can
hear 15 second rebuttal ms barnett then
we are moving on to the next topic yes
uh again uh we ran an amazing race and
this is just talking out of both sides
of your mouth do you have a crystal ball
how do you know how many votes
were were
whether through legal fraud whether
through outright fraud legal fraud
some of the fraud was against the law
some of it was completely legal fraud
nick and covet first question going to
miss sands the pandemic has raged for
two years and has impacted every segment
of our society and our economy as we all
know
hopefully
we'll never have to go through anything
like that again but if we do what have
we learned over the past two years that
would specifically shape your policy
priorities for the next pandemic we
begin with you miss sans in 60 seconds
well i'm wearing a helmet to start for
safety the pandemic i was serving as the
u.s ambassador in denmark and my team
and i watched what was happening here at
home we were shocked at how
democrats who are left-leaning and
mayors who are left-leaning treated
their citizens the lockdowns the the
they took their talking points their
efforts from the chinese communist party
who controls the uh world health
organization it's shocking how draconian
these rules were and how much they hurt
our seniors who were locked away our
businesses that that were destroyed and
our children who lost education and lost
their freedom we know
that the pandemic came from china from
the from wuhan and the chinese communist
party shut down the flights from wuhan
to the restaurant of china but they
encouraged the flights from wuhan to the
rest of the world and the world health
organization encouraged the same thing
it is controlled by the chinese
communist party citizens must say no
thank you never again to mandates
mr mccormick you have 66 is that
homophobic no more mandates two years
that would shape your policy priorities
in case in the event we have another
pandemic well i think what we've learned
is that the government overreach by
dictating everything from vaccines to
testing to mass protocols has brought
huge damage
on our population on our children on our
businesses and those decisions best
arrests with individuals
and and businesses to make the right
decisions for them and uh and so what
we've learned is we need to be careful
about not letting the government take
too much responsibility and control and
this is where um memorize cracks me up
because i hear all his statements about
kovan now and this is a guy who uh who
on national television said uh the
chinese were doing a great job with
coveted lockdown he did who who
complimented anthony fauci as a great
scientist and a great leader good and
who was the who was the guy who was out
there saying mask up mask up yeah i mean
and so um so we've had another flip-flop
in the case of covid by mehmet but it's
a serious problem because we can't have
the government intervening and taking
too much control we've got to let that
responsibility rest with individuals and
we are turning to mr oz same question
what lessons have you learned over the
past two years that would shape your
policy priorities for the next pandemic
60 seconds we witnessed a top-down
authoritarian controlling response by
government that was unable to accomplish
any of its major goals early on for the
first six weeks there was abject panic
everywhere we had no tests uh we didn't
have leaders that we knew we could trust
thank goodness president trump was able
to that was all under trump what is he
talking about but anthony fauci who was
the leader of that initial response
should be fired i've called for his
removal i would debate him i've hired he
should be killed instead of calling out
his failings but he's representative of
what we're witnessing now which is
middle level bureaucrats making
regulations and rules even though
they're unelected that dramatically
wasn't trump in charge this is very
strange when new jersey pennsylvania and
new york in terms of its response to
covet and they were three of the
strictest states so the mandates didn't
work we now know that but we've made
washington drunk with power with the
belief that they can actually micro rule
everything and you're seeing the
manifestations of that with our school
systems you're seeing it with energy
policy and you're seeing it at the
border all these examples of a top-down
authoritarian ineffective rule mr oz
30-second follow-up have you changed
your position on covet from the
beginning of the pandemic to now no and
i have it now just to be
completely
open with everybody how could you
possibly think that i was not
aggressively pushing back when i
remember
distinctly speaking on the sean hannity
show about the fact we should not keep
our schools closed and the amount of
hate mail and posts that came out that
effectively tried to cancel me it was
reflective and they were mean tweets too
i mean listen this guy took it on the
chin push back against orthodoxy the
right thing initially was to be cautious
doctors are careful when they walk into
the operating room until you get your
bearings but once you understand who
your teammates really are who you can
count on and how the patient is doing
you need to be cautious and then after
that do what's right for the patient
always all right thank you mr oz turning
to ms barnett 60 seconds what have you
learned over the last two years that
would define your policy priorities we
need to walk as free people
we need to remember that the constitute
that covet does not trump the us
constitution those are some very key
lessons that we should have learned
coming out of this we should have also
learned what kind of leadership we
really need at this moment
we lived through two years that felt
like literal hell jumped out on top of
us with democrats putting their foot on
our throats putting their foot on our
businesses he even had to work from home
it was crazy
we should have learned a very valuable
lesson of what kind of leader we need at
this moment we need people who are going
to be fighters we don't need people who
are globalist in the way that they have
oh oh my god their business and although
i think you're a magnanimous individual
but you and your corporation mccormick
you are part of the wef the world
economic forum you as well as you um uh
oz you and you and you economic forum
this is a very serious organization that
has a a mindset of pushing globalism
globalist environmental social
governance okay thank you and we need to
be mindful thank you ms barnett 15
second quick response sir mccormack mr
mccormick
well listen i've run i've run two
businesses wildly successful businesses
i'm not gonna apologize for my success i
have done business around the world it
makes me uniquely capable of
understanding so i'm thinking barnett is
the craziest of the five right i've
served in combat so i know how to deal
with the challenges we face all right
and just like president trump that
experience is going to make me a better
senator but that didn't have anything to
do with the world thank you let's
continue on with mr bartos let him have
a turn to speak here what specifically
have you learned over the past critical
question because like i want every
viewer to hear this during the pandemic
while we were shut down while our
schools were shut while our businesses
were shut well our communities were
ripped apart dave and his family were
living they were hunkered down i think
the magazine said in aspen colorado
which is lovely
but they were not in pennsylvania dave
was running a company where he
instituted as the ceo mass mandates
mehmet was living in new jersey i had my
sleeves rolled up on main streets across
all 67 counties raising money with a
great group i was leading the effort we
had lots of volunteers raising money and
helping over a thousand small business
owners on main street mom and pops keep
the doors open when our government and
this is the key takeaway our government
continued to put career politicians and
people who live at the highest levels of
the elite they continue to put policies
in place that favored the giant
companies over small mom and pops and
what i heard from the 600 plus business
owners i had the privilege to talk to
during the pandemic they don't want a
darn thing from the government except a
level playing field who are we as a
society if all that's left when this
dust finally clears are giant
corporations that is not pennsylvania
and that is not the kind of senator i'll
be all right thank you mr barton yet
they all want to reduce regulations on
corporations which allows the federal
government to prevent people from
entering the country during health
emergencies like a pandemic it was set
to expire may 23rd but just tonight
before we took the stage a federal judge
granted a temporary restraining order to
keep title 42 in place until another
court hearing javier bacera the u.s
department of health and human services
secretary recently addressed his concern
about extending title 42 listen to this
please
you use migration laws to deal with
migration challenge you you can't use
the cover of health to try to deal with
migration challenge
mr mccormick we're going to begin with
you do you agree with the judge who is
keeping title 42 in place and keeping
migrants outside the country or is that
managing a migration issue they just
said there's no covet problem you have
60 seconds why would you use title 42.
it was a right decision to keep title 42
in place and it's it's but you don't
think there's any health emergency you
don't even think people need to wear
masks see what the open border policies
of joe biden have done they have created
a huge flow across our borders it's
creating and adding to the fentanyl
crisis in pennsylvania it's contributing
to the crime in our sanctuary cities
like philadelphia it's putting huge
burden on our social services we've got
to secure the border we've got to be
unbelievable
you guys understand the issue right they
all go covid was overblown we don't need
masks we don't need closures there's
just it's just nothing's going on oh so
we'll end the special emergency order to
instantly deport people because of covid
right oh no no no no we need that we
need that for health emergencies and was
fined in 2017 agreed to the fact that
they had consciously hired illegal
immigrants and that 95 million fine is
the highest in the history of ice he's a
shareholder his family gets two to 10
million dollars a year from that company
mr oz
your turn do you support tonight's
ruling or are we managing a migration
issue with a public health order you
have 60 seconds i support the ruling we
have a city philadelphia was just lifted
its mass mandate after putting it on
four days ago universities all over the
country are putting masks back on
locking down my son was in medical
school similar situation telling me
firsthand how the kids don't want it but
they're forced so if we're going to
force our children and now in los
angeles you know there's a mandate for
all transportation so people aren't even
following the cdc rules why would we
drop the obligation for immigrants who
are coming into this country as part of
a cartel run human trafficking operation
that's basically subsidized by the weak
rules of the biden administration and
they're running narcotics across at the
same time 100 000 americans died last
year from narcotic overdose that's four
times more than died of covert under the
age of 50. and when it comes to david
mccormick and his progressively
desperate efforts to undermine me you're
picking on my wife's grandfather's
company where i have no management role
at all however you did have a management
role while bartos and i and many others
were struggling to deal with covet here
building the largest foreign hedge fund
ever in china which so much so that
president trump on his teletown hall on
friday said that uh there are some
things people pro-china people who would
like mister lunch thank you miss barnett
a federal judge not letting title 42
expire on may 23rd is that appropriate
or should public health orders be
controlling migration you have 60
seconds it is it is appropriate yes it
is you cannot have a national a state of
national emergency for the nation but
not have a national emergency as it
relates to covet at the border but that
is you know it's in line with a lot of
other illogical things that the biden
administration and democrats have forced
upon american people right now we are on
track of having over four million
unlawfully present people come into our
nation there is nothing racist there is
nothing dispassionate about wanting to
know who's coming into our country where
are they going how are they going to
take care of themselves that just makes
plain sense it's not just a fit and all
but it's the human interaction the human
suffering that is also coming into our
country we need to secure our border by
a variety of measures we need to enforce
the remain in mexico uh enforce the
first safe nation people should not be
allowed to asylum
to shop for asylum and lastly we need to
take a strong look at the uscis we have
1.5 million people trying to get into
the country legally and they're being
barred thank you mr bartos 60 seconds to
you the pandemic is keeping undocumented
immigrants
on the other side of the border is that
appropriate way to deal with the issue
you have 60 seconds the judge is correct
and even democrats running for
re-election are running away from the
biden administration on this issue that
tells you how bad the biden
administration is on title 42 and on the
border the border is an unmitigated
disaster
well these candidates fight with each
other i'm running to fight for main
street pennsylvania and the sons and
daughters of main street pennsylvania
are dying by the hundreds because of
fentanyl that's crossing our southern
border we have a southern border that's
porous criminals are crossing the border
fentanyl is crossing the border and main
street pennsylvania's across all 60
counties 67 counties are suffering and
dying we need a strong border we need to
build the wall we need to enforce the
policies that worked under the trump
administration whether it's remained in
mexico title 42 and other policies and
we need to fight for good paying jobs
safe and secure communities and parental
choice and for all empowering parents
and students across all 67 counties
saving main street pennsylvania means
those three issues it starts in many
cases with a secure border thank you
returning to miss hans was the judge
correct and extending title 42 and what
do you say to critics who insists that
that's managing migration through a
public health order you have 60 seconds
you know we need to secure our border
and build the wall everything president
trump put in place worked we had the
most secure border in my lifetime
directly
last year of his presidency in the
senate and in the house we're going to
put those policies back in place we're
going to need an america first president
to really get it done in 2024 but the
fact is we do have the biggest influx of
illegal immigration and i will just call
it an invasion into our country there it
is if we don't keep this in place
dehumanizing
they're invading we've released them
into the public of the biden
administration that's a disaster they're
giving them cash cards housing
transportation
phones and benefits that american
citizens don't get we have to secure our
border we have to build the wall and i
will just say mehmet oz he actually
praised the chinese communist party's
response to the pandemic and dave
mccormick could never have made the
billions he did without bowing to the
chinese communist party you do not make
billions in china without bowing to the
chinese countries we have a quick
follow-up ukrainian refugees are
crossing into the u.s along the southern
border forbes magazine estimates that
more than 3 000 ukrainian citizens were
processed in march that's a 12-fold
increase from february should we treat
ukrainian refugees differently than
other undocumented immigrants mr
mccormick 30 seconds good question
uh we we should uh we should treat
ukrainian refugees differently but we
should we should take care that not to
expand that envelope into a broader
program and the most important thing is
we need to support the ukrainians in
their fight for freedom we need to give
them all the lethal aid they need we
need to treat them differently how in a
calamity and it's because of the
weakness of joe biden in afghanistan and
our energy policy mr oz we're going to
give you 30 seconds should ukrainian
refugees be treated differently than
other undocumented immigrants no
ukrainian refugees should be coming
directly to america not through the
southern border where it's a lawless
environment that is profiting for
cartels oh my god you have to drain the
swamp not just in washington but at the
border people are making a lot of money
off of the weak response of the joe
biden administration and ukrainian
refugees maybe ukrainian maybe not who
knows who they are and we should be
directly allowing them to come in their
communities here in pennsylvania where
there are large ukrainian populations
who are inviting these people in and the
u.s government is not getting out even
if they're not ukrainian we should still
consider them ukrainian and treat them
differently you want to move on to
another topic quickly get to another
topic only 30 seconds for these
responses though beginning with you mr
oz the question has to do with
transgender athletes competing in
women's sports earlier this year upend
swimmer leah thomas won the 500
freestyle swim at the ncaa women's
championships before transitioning
competed with the u penn men's team in
2019 there was outrage coming out of the
victory of leah thomas by female
swimmers who thought it was unfair would
you vote in favor of legislation that
would prevent trans women from competing
in women's sports legislation seconds
yes biologic men don't let liberals
control the language biologic men should
biologically in sports i feel so
strongly about that i actually put it in
my ad and i believe across the board
we're missing the point here leah thomas
went to my alma mater penn
said nothing to protect those poor young
women who got up at six in the morning
practiced their whole lives to protect
their rights the ncaa cowardly said
nothing it was the parents of these poor
girls who loved their daughters more
than anything in the world who stood up
and said enough's enough you're hurting
our children what happened to title 9
support
thank you ms barnett 30 seconds would
you vote in favor of legislation that
would ban trans women from competing
women sports 30 seconds absolutely
biology matters biology is a reason will
any of them use the term tally whacker
do you guys think i find it to be unjust
i find it to be misogynist you cannot
come you cannot compete and get all the
benefits of being a man all your life
and then suddenly decide one day you
want to be a woman i find it to be
incredibly unjust not only do we need to
have laws that protect those who find
themselves outside of the norm of what
society may consider the norm but we
also must look at legislation that
protects our youngsters
same question would you vote in favor of
legislation that would prevent trans
women from competing the failure what
we're seeing happen at penn is again
another example the failure we see of
woke ceos woke corporation woke
institutions the ncaa failed those
swimmers period the ncaa failed the
highly paid executives at the ncaa
failed we have fought for six decades to
get our girls onto a level playing field
for athletics and we want to undo it all
because there's no courage from these
leaders i would support legislation to
ban it but it also we can't keep looking
to the government for that this falls on
the people who are hiring right thank
you
your comments in favor of legislation
that would prevent trans women from
competing
i actually yes in a word i actually
wrote an op-ed opposing transgender
athletes
men cannot compete against women it's
not he's just against trans athletes
period she's just against it as a
concept if you're trans you shouldn't
even be allowed to shoot hoops i will
ban
the indoctrination of children into
critical race theory where they teach
our children to hate each other and hate
their country
thank you mr federal 30 seconds
absolutely i would support that
legislation biological males should not
be able to compete with with females but
again mammoth i'm sorry to keep bringing
these things up but you did an entire
show in july 22nd 2015 that was about
eight seven eight nine year old children
and you were supporting those
conversations about transgender
transitions surgical things uh
treatments that would would be
irreversible
so i think we could all agree that
that's absolutely time
i don't wish
that's that's ten ten ten seconds to
respond david
could be my biographer he studied my
resume so carefully i do television
shows
about views that need to be expressed on
networking we have got to move on at our
producers what what a loser
they're all losers we're going to go in
reverse polling order beginning with ms
sands 30 seconds you're at the very
bottom miss sound please go first
i'm running for the u.s senate here in
pennsylvania i'm america first i'm a
pro-life pro first amendment pro-second
amendment constitutional conservative
america first businesswoman christian
and mom
i will never back down in fighting to
make pennsylvania a better place for our
families we've been going in the wrong
direction for over 40 years
this is the time for a turnaround i'm
asking for you to support me on may 17th
mr bartos 30 seconds i'm a kid from
reading who spent his entire life here
in the commonwealth i love pennsylvania
with every fiber of my being and as you
watched here tonight you got out of
state candidates fighting with each
other to all the viewers at home no i
will always fight for you and your
families i always have i always will i'd
be honored to have your support on may
17. thank you so much i'm miss barnett
30 seconds yes i am you i'm you
uh i have been traveling over 1500 miles
all across this commonwealth more than
any other candidate here when someone
mentions a county i see your faces i
hear your stories i'm sitting across the
table with you i've been in some very
i've been in million dollar homes i've
been in some very humble homes but these
are very serious times our country is in
trouble and we need people who not only
memorize our talking points but people
who have actually lived our talking
points and who will fight for you for 30
seconds mr ross about life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness life starts at
conception protect those little children
from indoctrination when they're young
make sure they're well educated and turn
out in the workforce to build successful
lives keep them safe from crime and
protect the borders
liberties about the first amendment and
the second amendment to protect the
first amendment and pursuit of happiness
for me is is about capitalism which is a
beautiful way of living your life and
individualism we don't want to be
collectivists that's what the democrats
are pushing for as republicans we have
to be exactly who we are
and be brave enough to act on it
meaningless stakes are high ladies and
gentlemen the country is headed in
absolutely the wrong direction i'm
battle tested i've served in our
military i've i've put america first
i've gone into combat i've built
businesses i built businesses and
created jobs in pennsylvania i'm an
outsider and i'll go fight for you
because i am you i grew up in bloomsburg
pennsylvania on that main street jeff
barters is talking about and the thing
you can count on with me
is i say what i believe
and i will do what i say and i'd be
honored uh to have your vote and
privilege to be your senator okay thank
you all we would like to thank all of
our candidates for participating in
tonight's debate and a reminder
pennsylvania's primary election is may
17th and be sure to tune in on wednesday
night at 8 pm as the republican
gubernatorial candidates will debate we
thank you for joining us we thank all
the candidates and have a great night
there we go there go the republicans
[Music]
what a group huh
[Music]
and there they go
wow what a disastrous debate i mean an
absolutely disastrous debate
um word salad afterwards just just
meaningless
just trash i i can't think of a worse
debate
um
i think i'd go for any of the four
democrats over any of those five people
i mean that was that was crazy
it was crazy
oh man
thanks to everybody who sent in
memberships during that blueberry babe
dave schmidt lady vintage liquid ice if
you have an amazon prime account
subscribe to my channel on twitch with
twitch prime it's free you're just
taking five bucks from jeff bezos and
sending it to me which is a pretty good
deal
i i think i mean i don't know you be the
judge
um
wow oh hold on a second
let's just ban someone
yeah all right we're just just banning a
few people here
uh
wow there
looks like there's a bunch of people we
need to ban actually well we'll do that
later thanks to health storm angel and
skittle stew for the twitch prime
subscriptions very much appreciate that
guys alright guys that does it for me
this was the second stream of the day
new podcast youtube clips videos all of
it tomorrow see you then